[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are responding to your
questions and disputes that you brought
to us when we asked you are you beefing
with a friend family member or partner
let us settle your dispute once and for
all serious funny or bizarre we're here
to help give us a call at 188 earpod one
so we're gonna do that with our many
years of settling disputes both with
each other and with others
we're peacemakers but we're problem
solvers problem solvers Engineers it's
not just about making peace it's about
being right every yeah right we're going
to tell you who definitively in your
dispute is Right unless we disagree
which is going to get awkward but before
we get into that I have a little update
I want to give you a little something
I've been sitting on since I arrived
here this morning oh uh as you know I
played in my first ever celebrity golf
tournament yesterday
oh yeah I did so you got to play with a
celebrity yeah I did
um yeah it was
the comedy gives back
second annual comedy gives back
Celebrity Golf Tournament and it was
funny because I just it's something I've
always wanted to do like I see like I
give back the comments yeah I see the uh
like the celebrity pro-ams and stuff and
I like Golf and I at least in some
circles and considered a celebrity so I
was like just you know a little bucket
list item let's play in one and see what
happens
so because I guess in some senses I am a
comedian I was included in this group of
about 25
stand-up comedians oh including the one
and only Bill Burr what a what a
standout stand-up comedian yeah so like
like legit stand-up comedians like
respected and established
stand-up comedians who are so good at
stand-up comedy that they get parts in
the Mandalorian like those kinds of
people right yep he was he was the most
well-known one there
in fact he may have been the only one
who they auctioned off playing with him
but they didn't auction off playing with
anybody else
so you were assigned to like a force
yeah a foursome and it ended up being a
twosome and then a threesome and then
the fourth guy didn't show up because he
got covered
long story but it was what they ended up
doing for me I guess because I was the
the Oddball of the internet guy
is as opposed to putting me with like a
group of four friends or like a group of
four people from a company there were
the Reps for the brands that were doing
things so like the liquid Death guy
because liquid death was supplying the
water for this just like they supplied
for mythicon big fan uh the guy who was
supplying the shirts for everybody and
then so you were the brandly and then
the poor guy there was a there was a
hole where if you got a hole in one you
want to pour Porsche Macan or whatever
um is it mecan or pecan Macan uh that
guy and then there was a another guy who
got covered in short so anyway
we did not win uh it was fun yes but the
thing that I was actually kind of
nervous about is that they said that
there was going to be a joke telling
contest at night at dinner in front of
all these Comedians and all the teams oh
and that the comedian from the team is
responsible for coming up with a joke
and delivering the joke joke telling
contest even that as a phrase seems like
Antiquated but
that's that's a big part of this it was
a joke like a joke joke telling contest
not a routine not a stand-up routine not
a story that happened to you it was like
you tell a joke joke like a joke with a
setup and a punch line
which interestingly like in that comedy
community
especially these guys who are of this uh
age middle age or whatever like you know
send out comedy in the 80s in like the
90s there's a lot of jokes there's kind
of a tradition of jokes and so they kind
of respect jokes especially
well and here's another thing that was
not you would not be surprised to know I
would have dropped out uh upon finding
this these you know comedians is uh they
kind of just they've kind of ignored a
lot of things that have changed in
society and they still just kind of say
whatever the hell they want to say yeah
in one sense I sort of respect that that
there's a place where that's happening
in comedy that's not your place it's not
my style but I respect it
um and so I knew I was like because they
were like anything goes
so I was like these are gonna it's gonna
be so dirty I'm just people are going to
say inappropriate things people are
going to say politically and correct
things you know none of this is being
recorded
but I was like supposedly I have to go I
gotta say I gotta do something dirty
right and I was also thinking
I need to do something original like I'm
gonna write my joke I'm not gonna go on
like Reddit and find a joke and you
can't do that even though that's what a
lot of them did a lot of them were like
this is my uncle's favorite joke or this
is a joke my dad told me multiple times
growing up that's different than going
on Reddit though
um if you're related to the person who
told you the joke the guy hosting it was
Ben Bailey you may remember him as the
guy who hosted cash cab oh yeah for 14
Seasons so he's a stand-up so he's
emceeing the thing yeah uh out of a dry
wit other other comedians who I'm
competing against now well I will I will
say Bill Burr was not feeling great so
he didn't stay for the joke contest
which took some pressure off okay good
but Randy did you meet Bill I did meet
Bill uh I met him before we started
playing told him I was representing uh
YouTube comedy
and uh what was his reaction to that he
was like ah is it Bo Burnham man it's
like I mean that dude is [ __ ] crazy
okay okay so yeah
um so that made me feel good and uh he
was very nice and I met he I met him at
the same time I met Greg Fitzsimmons who
you would recognize if I showed you a
picture of him uh got you know this like
guy who's been like you've seen him on
The Tonight Show whatever and he's been
around forever so he Greg was in it and
then uh Randy sklar of uh Randy and
Jason's Clarks Clark Brothers was was in
the Joe I went right after Randy okay
perfect
so I'm going I'm gonna deliver my joke
for you deliver your joke I'm gonna
deliver all of us uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
get I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna get up
there and do exactly what I did right I
grabbed the microphone well you're gonna
stand up no I'm gonna stay seated
because the microphone's here uh now I'm
gonna do word for word what I said sit
down comedy uh and people had done a lot
of like classic set up punchline jokes
just to let you know the world that
we're in
Ben Bailey says red McLaughlin everybody
smattering of applause
disclaimer
um I am an internet comedian
smattering of laughter
okay which means I don't know if they're
laughing or not
a little bit more laughter
my joke is short
foreign
why did my ex-wife cross the road
why
I don't know I don't keep up with that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh wow look at you using the F-bomb and
the bee bomb
that was good
Jenna and Brian laughed at it uh so and
I'll tell you I'm I'm just over here
shocked right I'm gonna I am not a joke
writer okay
so you made that up I made that up
yeah what but you don't have an ex-wife
yeah so you also made up an ex-wife yeah
right wow it's a joke the Liberties that
you're taking and uh Ben Bailey said
there was it I wouldn't say it killed
but it did it did well it was very
respectable it was like I would say I
didn't I didn't make it three crossed
the road
and then the answer is
well first you said why did you have to
lean back from your own mic and say why
no I was imitating the crowd or did
somebody do that that yeah that's what
when you're telling jokes to a crowd of
comedians they say why oh okay you know
they they give you the other thing and
they're not they're not going to jump on
it and like guess the answer like some
person at a comedy club like they're
comedians they're like this guy's
telling a joke so it's a great crowd for
that I don't know I don't keep up with
that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah uh my joke
is short tell me about that part of it
like why did you feel like you needed to
say because people have been saying that
if they had a short one
uh people will be like this is a long
one like settle in it's people like this
is short I feel like the I mean that may
have been a mistake I feel like if
you're open to construction oh I am but
I'm I'm not I'm not going to get into
joke writing just so you don't worry
I you made an excellent choice in having
such a staccato joke but I don't think
you should have said my joke is short
because that was kind of the the punch
of it was just how bam and it's over
because it the shortness of it is part
of the surprise but well but once you
say why did so and so across the road
you know that it's a short joke because
that's a classic structure of a short
joke so well that's another reason you
shouldn't have said that's a better
reason though I don't think that I cut
the joke off but it was more than I was
just kind of like feeding off of the
things that people have been saying I
will say what I have done I no let well
let me tell you right now that
um
I
I was definitely nervous because I was
just like I was just trying to save face
and say something you what you're
self-deprecated say something just do
something funny and unexpected and I
would say that you lowered the bar you
made a joke about it yeah right then you
said something you shouldn't have said
then you said a really a really good job
oh you like it so I I see that in the
vein I'm offended like Norm Macdonald
like I don't know how familiar you are
with like Norm Macdonald when he was
having he had a show for his internet
show there was this joke portion and it
was every joke that Norm Macdonald told
was always a misdirect it was like yeah
in that way
um so that's not based on any joke but
it's based on the
structure of like a Norm Macdonald joke
which is like I'm not going to give you
the thing that you thought I was gonna
give you I'm gonna give you it's a it's
a joke about the joke kinda how'd you
come up with that joke
it was not easy like because I came up
with like four others I'm not you would
think about a knock knock joke well no I
was trying to figure out like
how do you write a joke because we don't
write jokes and so I was like
yeah do I so what here's what I did I
would be like okay so there was this guy
and he and he was on a deserted island
and the only person that survived was
him and another beautiful woman and I
would just say something like that like
that sounds like the beginning of a joke
and now we just see if I could find a
way to a punchline I did that like on
and off like as I was driving as I was
doing other things like over the weekend
to yourself uh and I never arrived at
anything oh God that would have ruined
my weekend
um but then I was like you needed to go
short you need to go short yeah
um
and then I was like and you need to say
it short I was like what about uh what
about uh
what about why'd the chicken cross
around and I said yeah what's the take
on that was like why did my ex-wife
cross the road and the first time and so
I'll give you the like this was this was
my dirty one
and that and so I was like why did my XY
cross the road
why
to get to my neighbor's dick
so that was that was the first one right
and so nearly as good and I was like I
this is that's not good
um you know it's it's it's you know
that's not it and then when I came close
yeah oh yeah I mean that's why I didn't
use it yeah yeah I'm just saying that as
I'm running through it I'm not slamming
you I'm agreeing with you so uh and then
and I don't know I don't know how I came
up with it but I'm not saying that it's
great I'm just saying that I was
relieved when I came up with it because
I was like this crowd will appreciate
that and I'll at least walk out of here
now if I hadn't known that they were
just going to tell jokes that they knew
I would have gotten even a better joke
but I did make it to the final three
um Randy did make it to the final three
I'm trying to remember who else did
Fitzsimmons made it honestly I don't
really care and then at this point
medium but you didn't make it that's all
I care about who won
because what they did is they did a joke
off and they kept going oh it was an
older guy you weren't prepared for that
so so if you would have moved on it was
a new joke you didn't tell the same joke
because that doesn't really work my my
next joke was one that a friend that
Daniel strange had told me okay uh which
was not I mean he was just like uh what
time does Sean Connery arrive at
Wimbledon oh this is an accent joke
Tanish
foreign
there were people doing that kind of
joke that people I guess people who are
like I mean I kind of think you could
have said I don't care I don't keep up
with that [ __ ] [ __ ] would have
worked again that's what you would have
done that's what I would have done if I
hadn't made it and then if you would and
then if you would have kept making it
same punch line every time
um I could have been your jokes yeah I
think you can do it once I don't think
you can do it in a second a third time
dude finish the uh the uh like it was
they were so dirty they were shockingly
dirty oh no you know I'm not gonna
repeat it
uh but there was there was no doubt in
my mind when a couple of them were
delivered I was like I'm not I'm not and
I was I was very I was like be in the
middle of the pack yeah you know what
I'm saying yeah don't get to the finals
because then though you'll really expose
yourself
you know and that ain't funny right so
um yeah so that's why uh you know it was
it was a growing a growth experiment
growth experience is that what I'm
looking for how did you golf
um you know
okay moments of Brilliance moments of
embarrassment typical uh typical game of
golf we did not win see my ml was both
at the same time
that's not how I operate I know I have
true moments of Brilliance oh gosh where
you're just like oh my gosh that guy I
have true moments was he a college
golfer
I'm saying on the golf course
uh check out Stephen again's podcast
best friend's back all right
I want you to do it
um it's never too late
to check out a new podcast where where
people are connecting where friendships
are happening right before your ears
um
don't do it if you don't want to do it
for me do it for yourself best friends
back all right wherever you get your pie
I think you should do all things uh in
entertainment anything that we're doing
in mythical you should make a decision
to watch it for yourself
I'll do it for us we're making this
stuff for you I went to watch
um you know I went to the premiere of
Slumberland uh you'll see this on
Netflix it's a it's a movie with Jason
Momoa but the star of the movie is Marlo
Barkley and we me Christy and Lando went
to the premiere book it we went to that
entertainment event for her and her
family because we are very close friends
you know uh Lando and Marlo grew up
together I think Marlo's still 12. I
think her and land are about the same
age she's not 13 yet Marlo is a freaking
star of this movie oh yeah like and
Jason Momoa is like her her um
her supporting character basically
um so I went to that for her
but I was absolutely relieved to find
out that I stayed for me you know you go
to things to support your friends and
when it's a work of art
I like a movie it's like oh crap what am
I gonna what am I gonna say afterward if
it sucks
it was so good so I know it's not my
wreck this week but you just made me
think of it
um it paid off okay to do interviews for
somebody else check out Slumberland uh
if you have kids in that age range
uh they will love it it's it feels like
the type of story that you think should
have been done before but it at the same
time it's like a it I don't think it has
and it's like it deals with dreams and
it's like wholly original
very it's not that Fred Savage movie
very fun
um also a tearjerker where he goes
underneath his house or something and I
was so proud of Marlo she is so good
in it you remember we uh check out
Slumberland we wanted her to be uh when
she was just getting started with her
acting
we wanted her to be the little girl in
the episode of Buddy system where the
little girl comes to the that's right
the door selling the candy bar salesman
goes into this like
old like Frontier story
there was a conflict of her that's right
she was committed to something else or
whatever so we couldn't do it
we could have derailed her whole acting
career if she had done that buddy system
thing yeah it probably made the right
choice let's get into these voicemails I
mean it's about time to settle some
disputes I'm just going to start right
here at the top
a rentling I'm shooting with my mom
because she has eaten half of my freezer
all 20 breakfast sandwiches I just
bought from Costco
don't know what to do please help
oh dang I'm sorry
um I feel like I need more details like
was this in one sitting I know there's a
lot of breakfast over the course of if
she was that hungry two hours let her
have it
because if you but if you've got a 20
sandwich package from Costco
I would think that most people are
anticipating that lasting at least a
month you know unless you I mean even if
you're the kind of person who's eating
it every single morning that's three
week days yeah
we have breakfast sandwiches in our
freezer I do not eat them because I
don't think they can actually be good
for you and I eat a smoothie every
morning but my Easter breakfast my kids
eat them Christy doesn't eat them either
so we we don't have an experienced this
is Jimmy Dean yeah yeah that's what a
shepherd's into I um
have a reputation of of being one that
just unapologetically take people's
stuff after taking Tim's salsa from the
fridge for that GMM episode
[Music]
um yeah that wasn't a good look for me
and every time I see Tim now I still
feel bad about it but it sounds like her
mom is Unapologetic
are unconversant about it because she's
thinking she's the one that needs to do
something about it I think isn't it as
simple as a question
Mom do you know that
these mom what do you I don't know I'm
trying to think of like a non-accusatory
question that's because maybe you like
those breakfast sandwiches I bought for
myself don't you Mom what do you think
of those
in my mind those are my breakfast
sandwiches mom well I don't whose are
they in your mind I don't think that
that's necessarily I I don't think that
she is saying that her mom can't eat any
of her breakfast sandwiches she's saying
that her mom ate all of her breakfast
sandwiches yeah I don't know if she was
on vacation I don't know if her mom had
a breakfast party I don't know the
context but I am mom should be replacing
these breakfast sandwiches that she just
ate way too many and too short of a
period of a time and she obviously had
bought them not primarily or not
exclusively but primarily for herself
right I mean I'm assuming that
there's some sort of shared budget
you're sharing a house
uh you know it's not like this isn't
necessarily a roommate situation right
separate bank accounts this is my stuff
I have my name on it Mom budget it does
have some sort of uh a trump card to
play here I believe she's probably
cashing in from a budget perspective she
could be cashing in on a a parent tax
maybe if I knew that if I knew the
earlier in life she wasn't the kind of
mom who would reach over and eat some of
her kids food in a way that I have done
throughout my life then maybe she's just
making up for it all I know like a week
one one crazy binge like I said I'm not
one to talk here but at my house Lando
will Post-It note stuff in the fridge
and I know Tim did that with the salsa
uh it was extenuating circumstances I do
I need to apologize again Tim well hold
on but do you do this Orlando do you eat
landos
um
um
[Music]
some special Mochis in the freezer
um some special chocolate milks in the
fridge
um
leftovers that's that's where I get him
because he'll label the leftover but I
know he's not gonna go back and eat it
and so I feel like I'm doing a service
to just like glean the fridge from stuff
that is going to be thrown away if it's
not eaten today well at least you can
get him to label it like I I can't get
my kid my cats won't eat leftovers man I
ever I eat all the leftovers like that's
the first place I go at night it's like
what's left oh really yeah it just feels
I think that she should I I think you
got to try labeling that's my that's my
thing just start there yes it's a little
passive aggressive re-buy the sandwiches
yourself then you're in a position of
power
and you label it
or have a conversation with your mom if
you're on if you're still on speaking
terms yeah I do I I think this is just a
there's a easy solve here which is a
conversation and
um saying hey if you really like these
breakfast sandwiches which apparently
you do and I do as well maybe we get the
40 pack next time
right you know there's a compromise on
the horizon yeah
hi Rhett and Link My name is Robert I'm
calling from BC in Canada my wife and I
have a constant argument about what is
ground and what is floor
I like to call
the outside where anything is paved or
has cement on it anything like that the
ground or the floor she says that it's
still the ground my argument is that it
is called the floor because anything
that is not dirt can't be considered the
ground because it is made by people
so I think it's called the floor if you
think it's called the ground because
it's outside
so that's our argument that we
constantly have and it has created some
really funny moments in our marriage and
like You guys sell it for us all right
have a good day bye
well he said he'd like for us to settle
it for him it seems pretty simple Robert
you're wrong
the floor is inside the ground is
outside it's not about being man-made or
not unless it's something that's like
there's an exceptions to that but I
think that's the starting point I think
that I also think that Robert is maybe
you're right in some instances but it's
not the distinction is not inside and
outside
if it's inside it is floor and if it's
dirt outside it is ground like those
extremes and you're not letting me get
my thought out that's what I think and
then somewhere in the middle we can hash
it out it has nothing how do you
disagree with that being inside and
outside it has to do with whether or not
there is a canopy or a roof that's why
we call it the forest floor we don't
call it the floor is ground and that is
because there is a canopy of trees and
like on the floor on the forest floor
but you don't say on the floor of the
meadow or the floor of the valley
because that's open so it has to do not
with being outside but with being open
so a patio does not have a floor
unless it is a screened in porch
now you're now we're in a situation
where you can say that's the floor of
the porch it's all about whether or not
there is something over the top of you
and it doesn't have to be human made
it's just is there is there a clear shot
to the sky and if so whatever is
underneath you is not floor but ground
well that's nice Brett that is a nice
analysis
um but patio is neither floor nor ground
it is patio I agree with that
so if there's if there's no canopy over
your patio and it's still like a cement
just like a cement slab
you can't call it ground
because it's now I'm about to agree with
him because it's not because it's
man-made but you can't call it floor
because to your point there's no canopy
but if you were on a path a floor has to
have a canopy I agree with that yeah
but a forest floor is also ground
that's the there's common ground with
the forest in that it is both and I
think and a patio is neither I think
because it's just a patio it's a patio
like you look down it's like what is
that is that the patio floor is that the
patio ground is it the patio floor well
but bye I'm all over the place by Nature
a patio does not have a canopy
oh oh
yeah a porch the difference between a
porch and a patio is the canopy is the
canopy oh yeah and and if you're talking
about the retractable
canopy I have one of those that doesn't
count that doesn't make it a floor it's
not like oh it's a floor when it's out
and it's not no no no I'm talking about
there's got to be some supports this
thing's got to be able to stand up in
the Wind
because you need to be able to call it a
ceiling so if I'm on a porch
somewhere and I look up like I was
talking to your dad at mythicon about
the ceilings of porches
yeah that are painted blue and my
understanding based on all these
conversations that I had with people in
the South was that they're painted blue
because of like bugs which I never
believed but that was what people told
me like flies don't like the white the
blue light blue and your dad was like
it's like the sky
yeah it's like looking like the sky and
he says they also do mint green like
mint green or baby blue those are the
two colors but that's the ceiling of the
porch is what you would call that if I
was talking to a painter he would say
what color do you want me to paint the
the uh
the ceiling of the porch wouldn't he or
what do you say do you want me to paint
the underside of the awning
and I think he would say ceiling and
what what the port ceiling and then what
color do you want me to paint the floor
what color you want me to porch to the
floor to stain the patio floor the porch
floor but he went patio patio floor I'm
just trying it out patio I think is like
just a square
either concrete or wood or brick or
something that you might have an
umbrella on now my backyard is uh
pavers like individual Stones blade
you call it a deck because there is a
pool there but there's parts of it even
the part with the retractable awning not
a floor
I'm trying to think what I've called
that
like I need to I need to blow off the
the back that's what I just say I got
out of the back the back
I don't call it it's not ground and it's
not floor
pavers
yeah but what do you call that area the
back
you might call that a patio I'm glad we
could settle this
uh uh so I think that we found a third
alternative here that I don't know if it
was Illuminating at all but but there is
a canopy if there's a permanent canopy
then it's underneath it is the floor
and if it's if it's naturally occurring
uncannopied surface Outdoors that's
ground
and so at least take those things off
the table and if you've got an old
school house
there's plenty of houses that have dirt
floors and that is also the ground
but it also happens to be the floor of
the home
but it's a dirt floor yep so floor and
ground can be the same thing if your
floor is ground
there you go please explain to my
husband that watching your own kid is
not babysitting
thank you
oh this is heated I love the fact that
you could hear children just making a
racket in the background of the
voicemail yeah yeah like this is the
world from which
this lovely woman is
exasperatedly leaving us a voicemail
yeah you ever been guilty of this I'm
sure I mean I'm sure using the term
babysit to take care of your own kids I
don't know I've ever done even if you
don't use the term there's definitely
playing this card of like
why why I I watched them
you know I don't go so far to say I'm
babysitting the kids like it's a a paid
occupation but if you watch me like
you're implying I'm gonna watch the kids
see you I'm gonna watch the kids so you
can do something as opposed to the other
times when you don't watch them
which is usually
and our kids are of an age you know they
don't need to be watched anymore but
like when our kids were watching age I I
would always like use it as like a some
sort of a
a merit badge that never worked and it
and I agree it's not it wasn't valid you
know because
I mean Christy and Jesse
they were homeschool teachers you know
as well as
moms like they were so much of their
time was like
tenant of these children good gosh by
their own choice yeah yeah it wasn't um
just to be clear I kept telling Jesse
year after year you wanna
you wanna stop doing that stop watching
these kids
you need to stop you being a babysitter
um but yeah it's like when you step in
it would be like something something
exceptional yeah that's a card you can't
play my man yeah your wife's right uh
just stop using that term when you watch
the kids you cannot do that we have a
serious category you want to get into
like a serious one
and then come back to a less serious one
yeah because we might need a little a
little relief you know
um let's let's start here
are you written links me and my
girlfriend recently have been butting
heads a little bit she's been working a
lot and I'm very proud of all the work
that she's been doing and all the money
she's been saving she's trying to move
out right now so I understand why she's
been in her grind set in her you know
girl boss money moves era
but uh
sometimes I just want her to acknowledge
the fact that I am also still here
and that I am
you know a part of her life and someone
that
would like to spend time with her I uh
have a difficult
dilemma in my hands though because it's
an interesting dichotomy this feeling of
being so proud of her for working so
hard but at the same time
wishing that she would
at least admit a little bit that there
is a strain on our relationship because
of how much she works I'm not exactly
sure what to do and I would love your
guys's feedback help me out help out
this struggling mythical Beast anyway
appreciate you guys I love all you do
keep on keeping on
um I really do appreciate all your
content and all your happiness that you
give to the world have a good one
well okay as as that question was being
asked uh Jenna
couldn't stay in herself I mean she was
you know there so I kind of feel like we
should uh let the woman in the room
Jenna we'd love for you to kick this one
off to give us an initial reaction to
this question it it's
a conversation with
partner and yeah uh that is a
conversation that he needs to have with
her and his tone was a little I don't
think he meant
anything by it I think his tone came
across a little
iffy but it's clear
it's it's a hard thing to do because
because
what do you say when in that situation I
don't know it's just one of those where
it's like if if it if the roles were
reversed
um it would be a conversation you want
to have with your partner like if if the
man wasn't working too much and the and
the woman or whichever however the
partnership is
um
either way he's he he's feeling he
sounds real sad and I think it's he has
got to have that like set plan a date
night just the two of them get out of
their normal stuff and have a
conversation and another thing I think
that you all can advise on is one thing
about your relationships I think it's
really cool that you do is you have a
set day where you spend time with your
wives like you have you have planned
time with them that is part of your
schedule and it seems like with his
girlfriend's new schedule getting so
crazy and how amazing that is for her
that maybe they need to discuss
scheduled quality time well yeah it's
interesting because I feel like in some
senses there's a I can relate to this
right now right
um
you know over the past couple years
Jesse has really started doing and she
really kind of started leaning into her
interior design stuff and then really in
the in the past like two years
especially and then this year you know
she's taken on
a number of clients she just got through
with a really big project
and the way that her time was structured
which was very unusual for me was
getting home and she's she's working
she's working when I get home and she's
working into like we don't know we're
not like at least when it got to crunch
time we're not watching TV together now
when you've been married to somebody for
21 years
um
there in one sense it's like oh well
Jesse's busy right now I'm gonna go
watch uh something that she would never
watch with me it's like you know
opportunity yeah it's like because I am
we've I've spent a lot of time with her
and I'm going to continue to spend a lot
of time with her and this is sort of
extenuating circumstances yeah that yeah
that is a a good corollary point that
like the cumulative time but I don't
think that is applicable to this
particular situation I I'm just assuming
because it sounds like you know we're
kind of still building the relationship
in a lot of ways not I'm not building
the relationship anymore but you know
you know what I mean but there's also
this thing where it's like in the
context of my relationship with Jesse is
that so much of
um what her life has been about and what
her activities have revolved around and
where she lives revolves around is me in
my work right which which tends to be a
more
traditional you know it's given the
history of the world and the patriarchy
like that tends to be the situation it's
like well the man's gonna do this and
I've got to support him in doing this
and that was our story for you know a
really long time
now as the kids have gotten older and
and Jesse has a lot of aspirations and
dreams and things that she wants to do
uh quote unquote her uh I don't know I'm
gonna I'm gonna choose to say that he
was doing this in a loving way her girl
boss money making moves right I would
say
those terms that seems like it could be
right used anymore by women yeah right
yes there's other
uh but it's been an interesting thing
for me to be someone who I feel like
I've gotten not yeah I've gotten
she's done so much for me she's done so
much for me which I don't know the
history of their relationship but for me
there's this like oh I can go and be a
part of this thing that's all about
Jesse and I I kind of Fade Into the
background and kind of can support her
but as it relates to like our time
together even our date night has gotten
canceled for the past six weeks because
she's been so busy but that project is
over we'll we'll do the date night this
week we're kind of getting back as long
as we kind of return to the to the
normal of actually spending quality time
with each other
um and I I think that what Jenna was
saying in the beginning about
you know this is the these These are the
bread and butter conversations of a
relationship it's like when it comes to
stuff like this this is what this is
where the magic happens honestly if if
you can really connect
um in about not being able to connect I
think there's a way in is
not it's it's not corrective like don't
take a corrective approach maybe think
about having more of uh
um
still supportive and celebratory and
it's like I'm celebrating what you're
doing I'm supporting what you're doing
but it's creating a challenge that kind
of frames it but then your motive like
where you're coming from is what is love
and wanting to connect and missing a
level of intimacy and I think that you
know if you approach it from that angle
as long as that's truthful
that's gonna go a long way right
you know to say hey let's let's put is
there can we put some on the calendar
can we can we put a plan in place where
I don't feel threatened by what you're
going after but I can be your biggest
fan of champion but still have
my needs
met by you because it is a reality that
if you're if the time that you would
otherwise spend together is spent apart
because of work
you have to manage that reality in your
relationship some people
too busy professionals who work late and
are like we see each other on the
weekends and that's an agreement we've
agreed to that we've communicated that
we we have our expectations are in line
yeah it's all about obviously the
expectations are not aligned right now
and so
and you have to figure out can they be
aligned
and if they can't then
that's a different conversation you know
yeah leave us another voicemail
uh we'll put Jenna back on it
you stay serious
serious hey guys this is Mike from
Michigan so
I've been into beef with my sister for
oh 14 years now
and well let's just say she's not
exactly all the way there in the head
and she got in a fist fight with my dad
of all people who was extremely old at
the time and I was never able to forgive
her for it and I don't know how to
forgive her for it and now my niece and
nephew want to get involved with me her
kids and my niece is my goddaughter
and I don't know how to bring them back
into my life without bringing her into
my life I know it's horrible
to take your sister out of your life in
your way but it's just kind of something
I don't want to be involved in my life
anymore but I really want my niece and
nephew involved in my life if that makes
any sense sorry a little nervous but uh
if you guys can maybe approach us in a
way for me where I can get them back
into my life and somehow make it work
with my sister too I don't know if
that's possible but thanks guys
Wow Mike thanks for sharing your story I
our hearts go out to you I know when you
said in like 14 years like our hearts
just kind of dropped you know it's you
know
that's sad it seems like it's sad for
everybody involved and it's kind of
intimidating to speak into your
situation knowing only what you just
shared in the voicemail again I I thank
you for sharing it
um but I just want to acknowledge that
like we're definitely out of our depth
here so I think the the first thing I
want to do is just say you know from a
from a heart level just that like
we feel for you and um you know I've had
um estranged long-term relationships
and
um
it it it doesn't feel good because it's
not you know it's not the it's not the
natural order of things you see so many
you you know you imagine those
relationships where everything's working
out and you see people having
relationships with in this case their
siblings and it's what you don't have
and I just know how how difficult that
could be
um
I also know that there's situations and
again I we don't know enough about your
situation to like be prescriptive but in
general there's there is a reality where
it's it's the right decision it's the
best decision to put boundaries in place
and sometimes
and that's along the whole Spectrum
sometimes that means that there isn't
any contact and that may be that's the
best choice for some people in some
situations you know and there's this
whole range and when you've got
um nieces and nephews involved
um
that that a lot of times I I have to
think makes it hurt that that much more
yeah I think I mean I completely agree
that we're not you know we can't give
you specific advice but there are
principles that are true
that are true in your situation as well
light Link said to me I think
it's almost overused at this point the
term boundaries it's on it's it's it's
used as much as people labeling other
people narcissists it's like it's the
thing that we all do on social media but
there's a lot of Truth in it and it and
I think that
um
it's okay to set a boundary that is
painful to implement
because sometimes the pain that you and
someone else would experience with that
boundary did not exist is even greater
but both are painful like the boundary
being in place and the boundary not
being in place are both painful
experiences so sometimes there's just
there is not a great solution and I
don't know I mean I think that
conceivably depending on your
circumstances
and like what the proximity Is are you
in the same town how old are the niece
and nephew like is this the kind of
thing that if there was any kind of
contact it would lead to
um like what were the problems what were
the nature of the problems you kind of
have to think about it like that to
think what are the boundaries that I
could set I don't know maybe there is a
boundary that you can set where it's
like
um my contact with my sister is going to
be in relation to logistical things
regarding my time with her kids I'm not
saying that's what you should do but I'm
saying but there may be a creative
solution somewhere in the middle and and
it's like gerrymandering a new uh
District you have to navigate your
specific situation but draw the boundary
and communicate the boundary so it's
like right when I don't talk to you
about this it's because I'm setting this
boundary if you're not okay with that
then I'm not gonna I'm not gonna have
the boundary here at all of our the
boundary is going to be extended and I'm
going to have to push everybody out and
sometimes they they can move so it's not
like you're making
one decision and then that's it and it
so I guess the first thing we're saying
is you don't have to make an All or
Nothing decision there's like this whole
Spectrum along the way that you could
make these even if it's a convoluted
type of gerrymandered boundary but then
you know two days later or two months
later you might discover that that needs
to move
I mean it needs to tighten up or it
could it could loosen up I mean you know
there's
um
you know if if
if the forgiveness is at play
that you know it's
it's always something worth considering
but it's you know uh
it also depends on your personal
tolerance right right there are some
people who might be in a situation where
any contact with a person would be too
triggering for them where they just
can't do it and there might be
situations where it's like
this person is difficult
annoying whatever and inconvenience but
they but I'm not unsafe and I'm not
gonna be you know my mental health won't
be a compromise you only you know that
in a given situation it's a what your
your personal level of Tolerance is
there are people that you can choose to
have in your life so long as you know
the reality of what it means
right you can admit that reality to
yourself like finding finding a trusted
resource which could be a therapist I
think is a great uh Avenue to pursue for
something like this a sounding board
that you may have to pay for you know if
you don't have someone in your life
Jenna yeah I will say I do have uh
something comparable to that in my
history with certain family
uh my my speaking to especially that you
mentioned she's not right in the head so
perhaps there's some mental health
issues going on uh my father the last
five seven years of his life dipped
heavily into alcoholism and It
ultimately caused him to die uh from
chronic alcoholism and it was one of
those situations where it's similar to
mental health issues
it's a hard place to be in because you
know that person isn't their mental
health issue like that isn't who they
are in their entirety like you see
glimmers of who they could be and who
they were before who they are when
they're on the right medication when
they're not you know uh drinking kind of
scenarios and there were boundaries that
we had to set up and some of my family
members had much stronger boundaries
than I necessarily did but I also had a
couple boundaries as well and it was I
mean it's gut-wrenching when those
boundaries are broken
um but they're the boundaries that you
have to set uh
to protect everyone else and some things
that we would do was
um Dad could come to public events and
support us but he couldn't he couldn't
be drinking and if he had been drinking
we would steal his car keys like a whole
scenario so like if you want to test the
waters of of being able to see your
nieces and nephews because that must be
devastating that you're not able to be a
part of their lives and like a positive
role model to them as well
um I would suggest something a bit more
public like uh like if they have you
know if they have extracurriculars that
way you don't have to sit next to your
sister but you could still be there
supporting your niece and nephew just
like really low touch things and like
forgiveness changes like
14 years is a very long time to
um carry that and I feel for that and I
have known people who have been in
really awful abusive situations with
parents or with other siblings that as
they have all aged the boundaries have
opened up again like the lines of
communication have opened up again very
slowly so but I highly recommend yeah
certainly speaking to a healthcare
professional like a therapist on the
Beth best path forward but yeah I 100
feel this situation and there's no
easy way to do it
exactly
every path forward is is difficult
thanks Jenna for sharing that
when we went serious maybe all right so
we talked about going back let's mix it
up a little bit all right so now we're
going to take a hard left turn
hi Rhett and Link long
s and good mythical morning so I have a
dispute that my partner and I have had
when you're sitting down on the commode
and you go to clean up the area do you
do it from the front or back let me know
love you guys
well this is this is this is easy you're
supposed to go front to back
well that's not that wasn't what was
asked
it was do you go down oh from the front
or do you go from the from the back wipe
direction is it is yeah obviously that's
front to back everybody knows that for
especially if you have a vagina
um you don't want to be wiping the fecal
matter towards come on okay just to be
very specific you can get you know if
you got a ball sack you can get some
[ __ ] on your ball sack it's not the end
of the world but I don't recommend it
this is so great uh
but and again I do think that whether or
not just don't leave it there for 14
years to tie it into the last I think
whether or not you have a penis is
somewhat uh is somewhat uh relative you
know irrelevant relevant irrelevant well
no I'm saying that like it's too far
um I mean for me to try to go through
the space
I didn't even hear the question that way
uh I can't even hear the question did
you hear the question that way that it
was like you go in from the front of
your
no it's just it's just you don't do that
yeah but some people because apparently
apparently someone in this and someone
in this situation we don't know if it's
the caller or the or the the partner
because you have to go back to front
when wiping if you're reaching through
the front you're pushing you're
bulldozing you're pushing you're
bulldozing which is very difficult
that's not gonna work yeah yeah that's
not really a wipe that's a push
you don't want to do that um yes I think
you go around the back uh now the real
question is do you stand up or not
uh no
um if you stand up the cheeks come
together what are you talking about not
if you stand up and bend over
well then yeah but if you stand up and
then bend over the biggest ever come
together the bidet changes everything
just get a freaking bidet uh oh my God
is everything but it's the day and night
that's the difference but if I do not
have access to a bidet my final wipe is
a standing wipe so for so you can exit
that much quicker I just feel like I'm
like one more time just to make absolute
sure why would you stand up for the last
white I don't know it feels like a
ceremonial and you're bent over
ritualistic you're like hinging well
yeah you got yeah
huh I mean no one's watching
you know I'm not I mean I'm not it's not
a show for anybody
uh I'll take the video if you want
nope I don't okay thanks for asking
but okay hey Rhett and Link it's Kailyn
from New Jersey
um I'm beefing with my mom because she
thinks I'm a monster for not having a
toothpaste perfectly squeezed down to
the bottom every time I kind of think
you don't need to do that until you're
at the very end trying to get every
little bit of it out but uh I don't know
am I a monster you know I I appreciate
the question and the love Caitlyn you
are not a monster
and I think this represents an area of
growth for me and I would like to Pat
myself on the back you know I used to
think you had to squeeze from the bottom
I was in the mom's camp
but then I realized you know what who
gives a crap I mean just squeeze it from
wherever you have to do it because I
would have thought that Christy was did
it the quote unquote correct way as well
well Christy and I do not share
toothpaste do you use a different brand
yes okay but even if we didn't uh we
each have our own drawer with all of our
stuff in it and nothing shared
so that's a key here it's like heavier
on toothpaste and do whatever you want
with it yeah I have my own as well and I
I used to think that the right way to do
is to squeeze from the bottom because at
some point that is the right way but I
agree with you Katelyn you can wait to
the last till you need to do it and then
you just take it and you grab the end of
it and you put it on the edge of the
counter and you you you 90 degree that
thing over the counter and use it to get
all of the toothpaste to the end and get
get the last little bits out but you
don't have to do it every time the
reason why it's a personal growth for me
is because I can look at that
quote-unquote
imperfect tube of toothpaste that's just
been like squeezed like a monster in the
middle
and say you know what I can live with
this unsettling reality it's totally
fine
it's totally fine
and then it's an exposure therapy then
later I'll squeeze it all down there
I'll make sure it's all out
so Caitlyn your mom is a monster and I
used to be that monster well get your
own toothpaste have you noticed
that toothpaste Tube Technology has
largely for many Brands made this
argument irrelevant have you noticed
this trend that they
every single toothpaste that I've bought
in the past five years at least the
brands that I frequent
you know I'm not talking it's not 1985
toothpaste where it's just like it's not
like a foil container it's a toothpaste
tube that every time you squeeze it it
returns to its original shape every
single time like the quip toothpaste
tube is like that yeah and so and then I
have this um
I started using the uh after they told
me something about my enamel I started
using like the pronamel like enamel one
it does the same thing and then I just
got one because the last time I went to
the toothpaste to the toothpaste person
to the dentist they were like you know
we're gonna have to do a cleaning every
four months because you get build up so
fast and so I'm now I'm going I switched
to one that like attacks build up and
it's the same thing and it's just like
you just take it grasp it squeeze it and
it takes care of itself I think the
toothpaste people are trying to make
this dispute
irrelevant they're trying to take this
out of the conversation it but it
necessitates doing what I say which is
at a certain point at the end you can't
tell how empty it is but you got to do
that you got to do the pumps technique
the fold and squeeze all right that's
not well no I don't do the fold and
squeeze I don't do the roll up I do the
I do the hang it over the edge of the
counter it's actually a fun little thing
to do I've seen you a video if you want
okay
uh I'll be naked I think that I think
the fold in school
accomplishes the the same thing at least
in the tubes that I've currently it does
it does so I think that the world has
become a lot more time through
technology it's a lot more time to do
the fold and squeezing it's not worth it
you're taking it out and putting it on
the counter
that seems like it I'm I'm not really
it's an Easy Motion squeeze I'm picking
up fold it and squeezing it boom it's
done
and then when it gets down to like the
last ounce like if I can get too many
more days though some of it is being
sent the wrong direction those last two
brushes I'm not even interested in that
toothpaste call me wasteful all you want
to I'm not working hard for brushing my
teeth not working that hard for that
last two to the last two days I do it's
a personal Victory if you need a
personal victory in your life get the
last of the toothpaste out before you
why don't you get some scissors and cut
it open
ever thought of that oh my I've done
that
really yeah yeah it's a personal victory
if the scissors are already there like
I'm not gonna go find a cut into a
toothpaste tube yeah no that's a
different type of person right there I
mean it's different from me personal
victories personal victories
um okay I feel like the personal victory
for us today is that we covered a lot of
ground we covered a lot of emotions and
now we just need another recommendation
to go with my Slumberland
um I'm going to recommend a
a Creator a content creator
uh whose Tick Tock and YouTube channel I
quite enjoy okay
his name is Forrest valkai I think I'm
saying the last name
for us with two r's you are saying the
name but are you saying it correctly I
think I'm saying it correctly spell it
all uh forest with two r's and then Val
k a i okay
and he talks on YouTube and Tech talk
about on Tick Tock he is Renegade
science teacher but it just talks a lot
about things that I'm interested in
about
you know fossils and evolution he just
he just started a new series where he's
going into real depth about evolution
uh you know he's he's a good guy he's a
nice guy he's not
um he's a good boy trying to make fun of
people
and uh or to say that people are dumb or
whatever that's not his his point his
point is just like this is what we know
about this stuff
and it's pretty awesome
forest falci all right we'll speak at
you next week as always use hashtag ear
biscuits to continue the conversation in
written form and if you want to respond
anything we said today or in any episode
or to any of the prompts that we put out
on Twitter
you can call us at 188 earpod one
did I lose you yeah you did
I'm back though
bye hi I'm currently
being with my best friend I don't know
if we're gonna be ex-bust friends right
now but she accepted a job offer that
was sent out to me we were both offered
the job and we talked about it she said
she did not want the job that it was not
her career field it's not what she
wanted to do in the future
um and I really really wanted the job
and then they continue the offer to both
of us and she took it and when she took
it they decided to no longer give it to
me and needless to say
um I didn't take it well I think I
overreacted a little bit but yeah I
think I'm past it now I have a new job
and everything it's fine but I still
have a little bit of like resentment
with it thank you guys love you hey
Teresa Ann here I'm calling in reference
to the fact that I am beefing with my
sister once again just because she has a
child does she get the right to be the
sole host of every holiday thanks love
you guys keep up the great work hey
Rhett and Link this is Liddy from
Houston Texas I just wanted to call in
and try to get some advice for a beef I
currently have with my husband
um I am wanting to put our Christmas
tree up already I'm very excited about
the holiday season
I love how the Christmas tree just
lights up the room and all the cheer and
joy it brings to the house but of course
he does not want me to put it up until
after Thanksgiving
um but man I really want to put that
Christmas tree out thank you so much
love y'all bye to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the secular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
foreign
[Music]